okay Rob Reiner who do you think should
win Best Picture
who do I feed are you on the spot right
away who do I think should win yes who
was your choice I was I liked others
that was very upset about Selma not
getting the nominee because I feel that
that was at least an important movie
about real subject you know what I feel
like boyhood I like you know I know what
I thought was the best one well I know
nominations Nightcrawler
the Kree Posse they were a lot alike and
awesome with an awesome performance and
for whatever what who's Jake Gyllenhaal
it's and it says a lot about America
it's just it's there's a lot of I don't
understand [ __ ] this year with not great
movie I mean you know any Redmayne is
sensational in theory of everything but
I didn't think the movie worked as well
as it could have but them he was let me
ask you about that I watched that movie
Eddie and it's terrific yeah but Stephen
Hawking and all I could think cuz we
were talking about how recently on the
show but how like you know medical
science still a great mystery so much is
a great mystery in that kind of science
much more than climate science for
example and I thought the whole time I'm
being facetious are flipping about this
but the whole time I'm watching movie
I'm thinking Stephen Hawking every day
must get up and go I can figure out the
universe and they can't fix
that's right cuz they're not him mmm but
he can't even do it he's not that kind
of doctor I think it just says a lot of
doctors were busy human body else so
complicated thing but watch this Vice
episode they've got good news about
campus all right all right in a hard
years it'll probably all be done a
hundred I cannot wait that long no you
got it you gotta do better that's not
the drought happening I got this hey
seriously though if money were thrown at
climate change the way money is thrown
at cancer there would be a different
outcome yeah look how they cure cancer
really well but people but those you can
actually do something my whole life they
cured one thing polio
it might yeah I don't video nobody's
making money off of that I don't
Kaleo now can get a vaccine for polio so
we don't get it seems you think i
psychology is ruining our culture
no one's already ruined way before that
let's take it all what do you mean the
culture was ruined far before this
technology but your famously
anti-technology I'm not anti-technology
I just don't use it for that's right but
it's not a political stance
it was just I have no I never had a
typewriter I didn't have the old
machines
it's a machine thing so you count on
somebody else to type your writing yes
this begs the question that there was a
culture to begin with this one just said
do you understand what I said it no
Isaac lotion where's the culture what
was the culture I think all of these
forms of technology of remove the idea
of gatekeepers in a way where there used
to be the idea of a public square and
certain everyone kind of listen to the
same songs watch the same movies and a
technology is a tool people can use it
how they want right yeah but we yeah
we've gotten to a point now where
everybody knows every yeah out everybody
at all times and there was a good
there's a great documentary if you ever
see it is called we live in public and
it's about the guy who was like who
created before myspace this was even
before you know Facebook or anything and
he said Andy Warhol had it wrong people
don't want to be famous for 15 minutes
they want to be famous 15 minutes every
day and so you have all the social media
which basically is all about look at me
look at me look at me look at me and we
are now looking at each other constantly
and you've got people being able to hack
into banks and steal a billion dollars
or 80 million dollars from ATMs and
everybody has access to everything now
and it's it's not to me not can create
the Arab Spring to though absolute you
what else what its resounding success
that whoa we're not done have this idea
of citizen journalism to which has
definitely its faults but this idea that
you have a few people who control the
narrative completely whereas you can
have people out in the streets
contributing and generating something
that otherwise wouldn't be out there so
more people can be wrong now well it
cuts both ways yeah when you can use it
for good or bad Keepers yeah you tell me
a little bit more about that what do you
mean by that like before when everybody
wasn't able to
you think this is better now I don't
think it's necessarily better it's
different which means there's going to
be good part things that are better now
and there's all going to be things that
are bad I mean I'm a journalist and all
the time I'm trying to figure out
whether something that's being
perpetuated and swept up in social media
is actually true and legitimate I feel
like it's a little like the Saddam
Hussein thing the gatekeepers it a lot
wrong with them but it's still better
than like what we have that it also
might be stifling voices that are very
legitimate and aren't being represented
of that class like if you think of a
class of editors who are the people at
the top for instance controlling media
is that mostly well-to-do people are
those people mostly white are they
mostly male so this is kind of what I'm
referring to as well well in the
internet the skill you have to teach
students now is how to sort through more
information but in general in other
words in the old days you'd go to the
library and look it up and you would
find the atomic number of rubidium and
it would be correct but now or are you
looking in history book and somebody had
written the history book in that but now
there's literally millions of sources of
history and so the student the kit
everybody has to learn to sift through
that this I just think we're living
through a transition people will get
used to people but I thought it was a
bug I think we're less informed now than
we were I believe but I don't think
we've really learned how to use
technology to our best advantage as a
culture as a society I think that's what
we're waiting for we're still as adults
we're still kids with technology was the
Encyclopedia Britannica better than
Wikipedia well I would say now sis that
yeah I think so yeah yeah I got to
disagree kids so really really Wikipedia
what Wikipedia I'm not saying more
accessible we get it they don't know a
comedians easier but more Gabor accurate
continually being updated and also it
but some facts fixin by are stable
that's isn't that true certain facts are
stable I mean there's certain thing
science friends yes yeah but science is
changing or everything can be challenged
in real time and should be attended
right look we're on television now our
we're on the Internet
before we were on television and Fran
even though you don't have a cell phone
I've heard
you know I know you've heard of them but
we're on we're a camera is taking our
picture at an average of 17 to 18 times
a day what yeah whether it's in the
store right your place you go you're on
camera
oh we're seeing you so this is one
reason why crime is down they can see
you doing everything that yeah it's in
the park yes and they still do it after
every crime they show you a movie of the
crime right okay yeah but right the
crime change the crime has change you
don't it's not about going to the store
and stealing something it's about using
the goal of the internet and hacking
inside why street crime is down it's so
1998 you robbed a bank with a gun right
you don't hate you all you got a dish
back into the bank account oh yeah yeah
you got it takes Internet security
seriously you can't just use your name
for a password you got right in there
you got to take what's bun so think
about this for a second bill you you you
know all these big multinational
corporations they hire people to hack
their systems so that they can develop
software to prevent hacking and they get
the most sophisticated people to do who
says that those people are not gonna be
criminals and so I mean how many how do
you how many short stories are written
about the safecracker hired to crack the
safe yeah okay this is it's the same
yeah you know bus but now it's really
scary because they have access to
everything
well this so you got to be even more
careful okay
oh no I can't do it change your password
Rob yeah sophisticated about will the
Republicans efforts to rollback Obama's
executive action on immigration come
back to haunt them in the next election
well it's probably not gonna get them a
lot of votes in the Hispanic community
it potentially could come back to get
them I mean but if you look at the 2013
government shutdown when the American
public that by a majority blame that on
Republicans and everyone thought oh this
is going to be their downfall in the
midterm by the time the midterm rolled
around a year later people kind of
forgot so I don't know if that's still
going to play out but this could be a
big problem for them because you know
after the 2012 election when they had
that autopsy the GOP had the autopsy of
what went wrong which is a very lovely
thing to call the document the only
policy recommendation within that is
that Republicans have to do something on
raishin reform and this is still a big
problem for them and a big issue it's
our doing something they're just doing
the opposite of what they should be
doing correct well and there are people
within the GOP they're very interested
in immigration they're interested in
stopping it
well there are people in the GOP and
lawmakers on the hill who they're there
they want to do something on it but the
problem is is when you have a bigger
tent of people you have a lot more
diverse opinions and you have a lot of
people on the very far right and also
conservatives hardliners on immigration
who don't want anything to happen that
could be perceived as amnesty these are
corners people would you deport those
people but you're gonna you're gonna
find that that the lawsuit that they
filed a federal lawsuit is not it was
ruled on a procedural issue and it's
going to make its way through the courts
and they're gonna lose I mean the Obama
is going to win I believe on that
because it's like Obamacare at this
point they're trying to stop Obamacare
they file a lawsuit and at a certain
point you've got 11 million people
signing up so what's going to happen to
those 11 million people you can just all
of a sudden gonna lose their health care
it's it's a practical disaster if the
courts rule the other way and I think
it's going to be a disaster for the
Republicans if they don't decide that
this is something they should be doing
the problem with this though is that
it's an executive action it's not a law
honestly it gets delayed and all of
these immigrants who were waiting to do
this and get this protection aren't
actually able to this also affects
Obama's legacy and Democrats could take
some of the blame as well getting to the
point we were making before you said
they had an autopsy they did right after
the election I remember Bobby Jindal
said the Republican Party has to stop
being the party of stupid I'm not
paraphrasing it was rich
yeah there's no volcán he doesn't have -
himself ran back to stupid yeah
ran back just do any comfortable it's
stupid well the party has come here
they're very comfortable it's a very
social guys what if we read if we were
able to redistricting districts well
there will and that is a big thing in
2000 that's he's employed that keep
absolute would it changed things of
course they don't have to cater to
minorities cuz there are no minorities
in their Disney what if Abraham Lincoln
had listened
go cuz that's the red states okay when
you look at that let you map that's the
red stairways you know and who's so
eager to keep them you know what though
you know some of my best friends as they
say yeah I'm in the South all the time
it's not like that in the cities I mean
no it's a whole night I played
Birmingham Alabama last year played
Mobile Alabama was just in some place in
Georgia or Macon Georgia when it's not a
it's not a regional thing it's a city
country thing when you're in the cities
they look at least my crowd looks like
anywhere else in America it's a city
country thing of the south but not for
instance a in Connecticut okay so know
there's a southern aspect of this crime
I know but come on we can't let this out
go we have to we have to bring them
along
I admit they are bringing up the rear I
mean did you see our basket full of
NASCAR yeah all right thank you
everybody thank you final piece